[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain a canadian science fiction
thriller film called radius spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
the movie opens with bright lightning
striking the ground following the storm
a man wakes up in the middle of the
woods injured and disoriented he gets
flashes of himself panicking right
before a car crash initially he thinks
he might have dreamt of the crash but
upon spotting the car behind him it is
clear that something terrible has
happened the man doesn't remember how he
got there and starts walking to the
nearest town on the way he comes across
a car and tries asking for help however
the person swerves and carelessly stops
on the side of the road upon checking he
sees that the driver is dead her eyes
have turned foggy as if the cause of the
death is a disease the man immediately
gets her phone and calls 9-1-1 the
operator inquires about his emergency
before asking him his name and location
only then does the guy realize that he
doesn't remember a single thing about
himself he doesn't even know if he has a
name or a family member he hangs up the
call in confusion and brings his wallet
out his driver's license says he has no
name which confuses him even more as he
contemplates what he should do next a
dead crow falls on the car's roof its
eye is also hazy like that of the dead
woman the man ignores it and makes his
way towards the nearest town he finally
arrives at a diner but inside everyone
is dead and their eyes are foggy he
freaks out assuming the deaths are
caused by some contagious virus he
rushes outside just in time to witness
another death of a truck driver he
quickly covers his nose and gets a map
from the diner before making his way to
the address written on his driver's
license a while later he reaches a house
that might belong to him at first he
knocks on the door and when no one opens
it he decides to break in after
listening to the voicemail set on his
phone he recognizes his voice and is
finally sure that the house belongs to
him he also finds out that his name is
liam still confused liam cleans up and
turns the tv on the deaths he witnessed
earlier are being investigated at the
national level experts speculate it
could be biological warfare or a
naturally created deadly virus either
way people are advised to stay home liam
notices a man working nearby in the
field and tells him it is not safe
outside the person doesn't make out what
he is saying and walks towards him
suddenly his eyes turn foggy and he
falls dead liam is not brave enough to
go outside hence instead he writes what
he knows about the deaths and stays home
he keeps up with the news and figures
out that the deaths are too heavily
localized for it to be a virus in fact
every death that occurred has been near
or around him then he hears a crow
calling and goes outside to check when
he gets closer to the bird it dies the
same death that liam has been witnessing
until now at this instant a wild theory
comes to his mind he believes that he
might be the cause of the deaths as
everyone who died was around him he
doesn't want to test the theory because
that means more people would die at
first liam contemplates calling the
police and telling them everything but
the question remains if they will even
believe him even if they do he will
probably become the subject of strange
experiments so liam decides to take care
of the matter on his own he gathers food
and supplies and locks himself in the
garage near his house later that day the
police come looking for him because his
car was found crashed in the woods liam
runs outside to hide as far away from
them as possible one of the officers
almost catches him but is stopped when
birds fall dead in front of her they run
away immediately after realizing the
unexplained deaths are occurring again
at night liam dreams of the car crash
and wakes up to find a woman in his
driveway she hears him in the garage and
comes closer liam warns her to stay away
but she doesn't listen a while later he
opens the door and surprisingly enough
the woman is still alive she reveals
that her name is jane she doesn't
remember anything else about herself
since this morning when she woke up in a
hospital the staff told her that she was
in a car crash and the car belonged to
liam hence she is here to ask if he
knows her both of them are as surprised
as each other they remember glimpses of
the crash but do not know what caused it
or why they were together as they talk a
puppy approaches liam and doesn't die
this makes him believe that he is not
the center of the deaths after all he
doesn't tell jane about his theory and
the two go to his house together they
try to figure out if they live together
but it seems like liam lives on his own
suddenly he looks at her reflection and
remembers her getting inside his car on
the day the accident occurred this gives
him an idea and he quickly opens the map
they find a bridge near the place they
crashed and decide to go there to
investigate the following morning they
go to the said place but neither of them
associates any memory with it jane
reveals that the only thing she
remembers from her past is going to the
mall with her family as a child liam
thinks it is a good thing because this
would mean she still has a chance of
remembering other incidents just then
another memory comes to jane one night
she was on the bridge looking at a blank
piece of paper in her hands she threw it
into the water and liam was also beside
her the duo doesn't know what to think
of it but they are not ready to give up
yet they go to the crash site to see if
it brings more memories on reaching the
place they find a huge black circle on
the ground as they had expected seeing
the circle makes them remember more
glimpses from the night they know they
were standing on the opposite side of
the circle facing each other after the
accident liam also thinks that the
radius of the circle is the range of his
curse he tells jane that the death
started with him and about how they
stopped after he met her jane panics and
refuses to work with him anymore afraid
for her life she tries running away as
he follows her they stop when a car
pulls over and a woman comes out of it
introducing herself as a cop she
recognizes liam as the guy whose car
they found in the woods as she keeps him
busy jane runs away just when she is far
enough the cop falls dead it is clear
that jane acts as an antidote to liam's
curse whenever she is around no one dies
but as soon as she is away from him the
unexplained deaths occur to prove the
theory liam brings jane to a field with
a goat and asks her to walk away slowly
once she is outside the radius the
animal dies making her believe that liam
is right following that the duo goes to
the hospital to get an mri scan they
believe the results will tell them what
is causing the deaths they stay close to
each other throughout the procedure but
in the end the results say they are
normal at the same time they hear liam's
name on the news the police have found
the cops and the farmer's dead bodies
and related the murders to him the duo
knows that if he is arrested and taken
away from her more people will be killed
upon realizing the cops are already at
the hospital they quickly run to the
elevator liam gets inside but jane is
distracted by the missing person posters
on the wall it makes her recall that the
paper she was looking at on the bridge
was not blank it was a missing person's
poster with a picture of herself back in
the present liam loses jane and
dreadfully gets ready to witness more
death he tells the people with him to
run outside as fast as they can when the
elevator door opens they do as told and
jane comes to him at the same time
thankfully no one is killed in the
incident following that they drive to a
fenced property and spend the night in
the car liam again wakes up from the
nightmare of the crash a while later
jane listens to the news on the radio
the police have found out that she is
with liam too her husband sam is at a
report conference begging her to come
back jane is shocked because she didn't
know she was married they go to meet him
in private and convince him to help them
initially the guy just thinks he's
getting cocked and doesn't believe the
two but when liam demonstrates his curse
by killing some birds sam has no choice
but to believe them the three go to his
office where they can hide for a while
there liam finds a missing person's
poster that jane was holding in her
memory it has her picture but the name
of a different girl sam explains that
jane's real name is rose and the girl in
the picture is her twin sister lily she
went missing a few months ago and never
came back her disappearance caused jane
to fall into a spiral of depression she
was too obsessed with finding out where
lily went which caused an argument
between her and sam this is when she
left a few days ago and came back only
today the story fills a huge gap in
jane's memory making her remember more
things that night she gave up on looking
for her sister and was about to commit
the unthinkable on the bridge liam found
her and saved her life they were driving
somewhere away from the bridge when the
accident happened she tells liam that he
saved her life and thanks him later sam
finds her sleeping on liam's lap and
gets jealous he calls the police but
regrets it instantly when the cops
arrive they separate liam and jane
causing their own deaths and the deaths
of the pedestrians nearby after everyone
dies sam asks the duo to run away
promising that he will take care of
things by now liam has an idea of where
they were going after the crash he
thinks they were driving to a secluded
cabin that he owns they stop at a gas
station where a news broadcast catches
their attention on the night of the
crash an unexplained cosmic anomaly
struck the earth at the exact spot where
they had the accident the duo believes
it might be the cause of the strange
things happening to them but have no way
to prove it in the following scene they
arrive at the cabin that is near a lake
they chat for a long time about their
future and everything that has happened
until now even if they convince the
authorities that the cosmic anomaly was
the cause of the deaths what then they
will have to be confined and kept
together for their entire lives liam
thinks it is unfair to jane since she
will be his babysitter but jane claims
that she wouldn't mind living a life
like that since the cabin is far from
the nearest town liam can stay away from
her without killing anyone he goes to
the lake nearby and gets on a boat a lot
of fish are about to die at the same
time jane finds a journal in the
fireplace
inside it are several missing person
posters with a detailed note about each
person jane skims through it and finds
her sister's missing poster in the end
then there is her real name written on
the top of the next page it is finally
revealed that liam is a serial killer
who kidnaps and kills women he is on the
boat getting the same flashback as jane
he realizes the truth and remembers how
he killed jane's sister and threw her
body into the water he was about to do
the same with jane as well that night
when they were driving to the cabin jane
noticed he was trying to sedate her they
got into an altercation which caused the
crash however both of them got out of
the car unharmed once they were outside
the cosmic incident occurred and trapped
them inside dome-shaped energy they do
not remember what happened afterwards
but the pieces have finally come
together liam comes outside the lake and
vomits at the thought of the horrible
things he did when he was his former
self suddenly jane arrives with a gun
and asks him to bring her sister back
from the lake she is about to kill him
but cannot get herself to do it they
return to the cabin and find a bunch of
men outside the group thinks they are
terrorists and attacks them liam runs
away a bit further and kills two of the
thugs meanwhile the last one panics and
shoots jane he also dies a while later
but jane is severely hurt in the process
liam rushes her to the hospital and
watches the doctors take her away he no
longer resonates with the serial killer
he was and feels disgusted with himself
for what he did in the past in the end
he commits the unthinkable to prevent
any other deaths whoa
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching